i'm joined by professor jonathan van tam
the deputy chief medical officer
and dr nikki kanani the medical director
for primary care at
nhs england today we've got an update
in our fight against coronavirus both
here at home
and around the world and i'll start
by talking about events around the world
we've all seen the
harrowing pictures of what's happening
in india
and i think it pains each one of us uh
who's who's seeing those scenes not
least because the bonds between our
countries
are so strong and they're ties of
family and of friendship i've been in
constant contact with my
indian counterpart and we worked over
the weekend
to put together our first package of
support of ventilators
and oxygen concentrators more supplies
will be arriving
later this week i've also been working
with the health minister for northern
ireland
robin swan to donate large-scale
oxygen production equipment from
northern ireland capable of producing
over a thousand liters of oxygen per
minute
which is one of the main needs of the
people of india
and i'd like to thank robin for the
incredible hard work he's done
in getting this to the position it is so
that we can
get it sent to india where it can
produce that oxygen that's so badly
needed
everyone across this whole united
kingdom
stands side by side with the people of
india in these troubled times
because in this battle against
coronavirus
we're all on the same side this fight is
a global fight
and when other nations face their hour
of need
as we've faced our hour of need here at
home
we'll be there the situation in india
is a stark reminder that this
isn't over yet it shows
how important it is that we are vigilant
here at home and professor van tam will
take us through the data
in a moment but just before we do i want
to give an
update on the vaccination program this
morning we published new data
giving the first concrete evidence of
how
much vaccines reduce transmission
within households we've seen already
that a vaccine
reduces your chances of catching covid
by
around two-thirds this new data
looked at people who tested positive
after having received
one dose of the vaccine and found
that they were up to fifty percent less
likely to pass on the disease to someone
else in their household
and we're looking at whether the second
dose gives an
even bigger effect we know that
indoor settings have the highest risk of
transmission so these results
are really encouraging in terms of the
impact of the vaccine on reducing
transmission
we're finding out more and more about
the different layers of protection
you get from a vaccine and how it's
impacting in the real world
in summary we think that you get around
two-thirds protection from against
catching the disease at all
around four-fifths reduction in your
likelihood
of ending up in hospital and around 85
percent
protection from dying of covid
that's the protection you get from one
dose
and in addition to all that you're up to
half as likely to pass it on to somebody
else that you live with
we expect the benefits to be even
greater after two doses and we're
monitoring that carefully
but what this means is the evidence is
stacking up
that the vaccine protects you it
protects your loved ones
and it is the way out of this pandemic
the overall effectiveness of the
vaccination program
comes from just two things
one how effective the vaccine is that's
the
science if you like and two how many
people
get the jabs and that of course is on
all of us and i just want to turn to the
second of those
for a moment as well this chart
if we have the first animation please
this
shows the proportion of people
who've had the jab according to age
group
and you can see that the green bars
represent the people who've had one dose
and the blue represent people who've had
two and they
are growing over time as the vaccination
program
reaches more and more people who are
younger
and younger and as you can see across
the uk
uptake of the first dose amongst the
over
50s is phenomenally high
at over 95 percent and is rising
sharply in people in their late 40s
who've been
now able to receive the the vaccine for
a couple of weeks
this is great progress and it's
something we can all celebrate
because we all have a part to play in
this
and i'm delighted that we've been able
to offer the vaccine now to even more
people
so anyone who is 42 or
older can now come forward and get the
jab
i'm delighted about this uh because it
shows the great progress that we're
making
and i'm also delighted because it means
i can get my jab too
just like every other 42 year old and 43
year old
i got a text from the nhs yesterday
i went online i booked it for myself
it takes less than a minute and i'm
looking forward to getting my jab
first thing tomorrow morning in the
words of our
new campaign every vaccination
brings us hope so we've looked at the
effectiveness of the vaccine
and we've looked at the take up of the
vaccine now i want to turn to the
combination of the two
what i'm about to show you is not how
many people have had the jab
but how many people have got the
antibodies
that that that make the jab effective
these antibodies that protect you from
coronavirus
this isn't a measure of the vaccination
program directly
this is a measure of the protection that
we have
collectively built up in people right
across the country if we can have the uh
the second chart please this data
released today by the office for
national statistics
is from the a national survey where they
visit
over 20 000 people and they actually
measure the antibodies in people's
bloodstreams
the blue area shows the proportion of
people who have covid19
antibodies as you can see the in the
older age groups
those who got vaccinated first they are
much more likely to have
covid19 antibodies so more and more
people
are getting protection and now seven in
ten adults
have protective covid antibodies
this is the vaccination program in
action
and it makes me so proud of what we've
done
we have been working on the vaccine
program for more than a year now
there's a massive team to it and i'm
very very grateful to them all
but the thing that makes me proudest is
how
when the call came the whole nation
who's been asked
has effectively stepped forward because
this vaccination program depends yes on
the effectiveness of the science
and that is crucial but it depends on
everybody stepping forward
the vaccine is helping us to bring back
our freedom and we must protect this
progress
the biggest risk to that progress is the
risk
posed by a new variant so we're working
on our plans for booster shots too and
this is the final thing i want to
talk about to keep us safe
and free here while we get this disease
under control across the whole world
we have been working on a program of
booster shots
again for over a year now and we've
backed some
of the only clinical trials in the world
looking specifically
at booster shots i'm delighted to be
able to tell you
that we've secured a further 60 million
doses of the pfizer beyondtech vaccine
that will be used alongside others as
part of our booster shop program
later this year and that is
all about protecting the progress that
we've made
we have a clear route out of this crisis
but this is no time
for complacency it's a time for caution
so we can keep the virus under control
while we take the steps
safely back to normal life so please
remember
that the basics of hands face space
and fresh air and crucially
if like me you get the call
join me and get the jab